[Music]
inside out had you relived the end of
your childhood
so gave you an existential crisis now
the studio that loves to make children
stare death in the face
asks audiences to consider what if two
fish boys had a fun summer together
okay cause uh cause i could not handle
another coco right now
luca after the trailers made it look
like call me by your name
for kids prepare for what luca is
actually about
a sea creature obsessed with the surface
who comes out thanks to the
encouragement of an older boy that
enters a pasta eating contest to win a
scooter they don't need
and decides he'd rather go to astronomy
school instead
is it kind of breezy and unfocused by
pixar standards sure
is it better than the last five
dreamworks movies yes
will it make you wish you were a cartoon
who gets to live in pasta town
of course it will you're not a monster
journey to that region of italy where
everyone knows italian
[Music]
pieces
every family can afford that's full of
lush landscapes and sweeping vistas that
feel real enough to touch
while all the characters get the
bean-shaped head and noble smile of
every other cartoon made in the last 10
years
oh great now pixar looks the same too
meet luca a boy who works under the sea
finding nemo's
he's this generation's version of the
little mermaid but when this fish out of
water
also wants to be where the people are
he'll have to escape his jewish italian
mermom
if i have to send you to the bottom of
the ocean to keep you safe
so be it by teaming up with max mom beat
a guy at cards there once
you don't find me attractive no and run
away with alberto
a cartoon as free-spirited as jack dylan
grazer doing a junking interview
fire fire firefighter we're telling that
a lot i bought a houseboat
no you didn't yeah i did i have no money
left who is your favorite batman
oh great question uh well there's
countless i would say george clooney or
val kilmer
together these two wet little scamps
will team up with third wheel julia
to explore a rich world of mustache
characters like massimo
a one armed man without a tragic
backstory for his disability
what this is how i came into the world
senora marci glace
an italian entrepreneur who's not part
of the mob wait you can do that
and air collate a jackass bully without
some weepy excuse for why it turned out
that way
come on they're breaking on the movie
rules quick disney make a prequel where
a mob of fish eats dad's arm and kills
the bully's parents
phew and they better explain how he got
that sweater too more and more
more lord come on everybody more lord
come on do it with me more
more so dive in to another pixar thing
that you could poke full of holes if
that's what makes you happy like when
you're part fish
isn't this considered murder isn't this
considered genocide
and is someone that picks our own vespa
stock it's just the greatest thing that
humans ever
made the vespa it's so beautiful yes we
need it
wouldn't it be amazing to have a real
vespa we'd swim right over to vespa town
track down senior vespa
vespa vespa vespa wild fest
hey stop looking she's too beautiful for
you but it's a sweet short little film
with a nice message
that you can watch for free with your
loki subscription and in that one
inevitable moment in every pixar movie
that makes you cry
at least you won't be doing it in front
of a theater full of children
have fun daddy go back to hair robe
daddy's remembering what freedom felt
like
staring hook wine and sinker
peer pressure manic pasta dream girl
felici moe maya rudolph professional
cartoon mom fish don't even like fish
you know
that's why they're always frowning
they're like what's that smell
oh it's me i'm a fish and borax
subsequent movie fish well carcass chum
and summer
worst part about this movie now i'm sad
and hungry which usually means i'm
heading straight to the oliver garden
what's wrong with you stupido it doesn't
matter whether you win by an inch or a
mile
winning is winning you assumed epic
voice guy will read at your request
just like that think commenter think
with great power comes great wait i'm
not in this movie
come on